google attend toujours de se remettre du
déraillement de train survenu le mois
dernier le quatrième dans le nord de
l'ontario depuis le début de l'année le
canadien national a tiré des leçons de
l'accident et a réduit depuis la limite
de vitesse de ses convois entre le
manitoba et sudbury une mesure que la
compagnie étant maintenant à tout son
réseau au pays pour bien des mères c'est
une nouvelle encourageante
ce qu'on demande depuis deux années
ainsi dans les zones d'au moins cent
mille habitants la limite de vitesse
s'établira à 56 kilomètres à l'heure
pour les trains de plus de vingt wagons
transportant du pétrole brut une limite
qui pouvait atteindre les 100 kilomètres
à l'heure dans certaines zones jusqu'ici
les convois qui passe
ses 200 250 wagons lits lorsque sa route
sans qui la mettra en plus des dangereux
c'est le bruit les vibrations un pas
dans la bonne direction selon cet expert
si jamais il ya un impact se sentir ça
va être moins harris que ce soit au
niveau environnemental ou de votre
vision ça va être de moindre importance
mais les experts s'entendent la nouvelle
mesure ne réglera pas tous les problèmes
la longueur des convois les produits
transportés la formation du personnel et
l'inspection autant d'éléments qui doit
faire partie de la stratégie pour
réduire les risques d'accident et une
stratégie uniforme pour toutes les
compagnies ferroviaires s'impose selon
cet expert pourquoi est ce le seul qui
prend l'initiative et non pas transports
canada on ne sait pas si transports
canada à l'intention d'imposer une
mesure similaire à toutes les compagnies
mais chose certaine le canadien national
continuent de revoir ses pratiques et
pourrait annoncer d'autres changements
sous peu ici julian lamoureux radio
canada toronto
nombre de wagons citernes en circulation
au canada et d'ailleurs en forte hausse
en 2009 on en comptait 500 au pays
quatre ans plus tard en 2013 il y en
avait près de 300 fois plus c'est-à-dire
140000 il n'y a pas que leur nombre les
trains de pétrole et de marchandises au
canada sont de plus en plus long et de
plus en plus lourd l'art taille et leur
poids moyens sont trois fois plus
élevées au début des années 90